okay so house of the dragon episode 3 is
now out and the episode is filled with
easter eggs lots of plot points are
pulled from the books and an ending that
sets up some major things for the future
throughout this video we're going to be
breaking it all down and as always make
sure you subscribe as we're going to be
covering the show every single week and
this episode gives us a time jump of
three years that sees a new character
coming into the fold who we'll talk
about more in just a bit when we last
left them damon and corliss valerian had
just formed a pact in order to stop crab
feeder and his crappy forces this union
is symbolized in the opening shot which
shows his banner of the seahorse along
with the embers of fire representing
house targaryen we see that one of
corliss's ships is being burned by
crabfeta's forces and this
metaphorically shows how much they're
destroying his fleet cordless in the
book was said to have amassed the
biggest navy in the world and his
shipping realms allowed him to gain more
money than the lannisters though crab
feeder initially just started ransacking
pirates this eventually moved to the
bigger ships and he tortured the crews
like what we see here he hammered nails
through their hands similar to a
crucifixion and let the crabs feed on
his victims before the tide rolled in
and they all drowned this opening is so
powerful and we hear the high-pitched
whistle of karaxis before the dragon
rolls and destroys everything well lad
he thought he was gonna get saved but
the man gets smashed like that like
button i see you chump
now we can't really show most of this as
i don't want to get it day monetized hey
day monetized but crab feeder ends up
hiding in the caves which forces damon
to get his hands dirty and go in there
later now arrows rain down which makes
damon leave and it's likely that several
attacks like this have happened with the
dragon having to flee due to the
bombardment from the sky now as always
we're not really going to be giving away
any major spoilers such as the twists or
deaths but we will be talking about
certain things from the books to give
things more context this includes stuff
like who allison's unborn baby is the
thing that viz does that leads to more
issues with rhaenyra and a couple of
bits in here but nothing too crazy if
you don't want it if you don't want to
know anything yet
it's off now i also feel like there's
some major differences here from the
source material that are worth going
over so you understand why things have
played out the way that they did anyway
building off last week the book actually
saw the allegiances between damon and
corliss come with a title damon was
announced as being king of the
stepstones which this episode doesn't
really touch upon i'm also guessing that
they changed things up with miseria as
she isn't in the episode and also due to
the time jump that we had there seems to
be a lot of different things going on
now in the book the events from last
week played out similar to how they did
in the episode with becerras demanding
that damon returned to his wife damon
announced that mizeria was pregnant but
unlike the episode she actually was
however when the king said that damon
had to break off the marriage he sent
her away and she ended up losing the
baby he then formed the union with
corliss but he held a grudge against his
brother because of the death of his
child aegon was later born which pushed
him further down the line but it looks
like they're changing things up with
miseries baby just being a lie now in
the show it never existed and as many of
you pointed out on our last breakdown
she actually hinted that she made sure
that she couldn't have children so they
are kind of keeping things in line with
the book and having the baby never being
born but depending on whether it
actually existed or not depends on what
canon you subscribe to
make sure you subscribe as well and we
go to aegon's birthday and see that otto
has a couple more gray hairs and alison
has another one on the way also nice
little detail but i think they might
have moved viserys's hairline back a bit
showing how he's gotten slightly older
as well in the book when he was older he
was depicted as being bald so this is
keeping in line with how things develop
in the source material and that's why
this video is sponsored by keeps just
kidding it's so now this episode shows
where the fractures really start to form
in the family as ronira knows she'll be
looked over in favor of aegon most of
the crowd think he's the next in line
and we even get lines like this two
years old i'm already our boy has a
kingly presence well i think he's a
chump mate now even otto gets pressure
put on him to get the king to announce
that he's the new heir but he likely
sees the danger that this could put his
grandson in so he decides not to push it
there's also the talk of war with the
lannister popping up but what i think is
the first time in the series you can see
the house banner on his chest which
contains a golden lion on it and this is
thailand who meet before his brother
jason later on the pair are twins with
thailand being the elder but they're
both played by jefferson hall and they
become pivotal characters later on when
we get to the dance of the dragons this
is basically a term used to describe the
civil war that eventually comes to take
place the book also talks about his
brother jason's failure to secure
anira's hand which we see playing out in
the episode now the lannisters at this
point were of course quite far down the
chain in terms of houses and it would be
a long time before they built themselves
up to become the dominant house that we
see in the main series jaime lannister
would later go on to kill aerys
targaryen which ended up propping a
baratheon up on the throne and i loved
seeing how the family were almost
married here this video is sponsored by
established titles a gift that lets you
become like your favorite characters in
house of the dragon did you know there's
a traditional custom in scotland where
if you own a piece of land you can refer
to yourself as a lord lead or a lady
that's why i was super interested in
this project which allows you to get at
least one square foot of dedicated land
on a private estate in edelston scotland
so if you pick up a plot you can refer
to yourself as a lord whilst also
helping to preserve the picturesque
woodlands that exist there it's also a
great way to help out the environment as
established titles will plant one tree
for every single purchase they work with
global charities like one tree planet
and trees for the future to help out
with reforestation efforts and there
also comes a bit of an ego boost on top
of all the environmental stuff you
yes you you can officially change your
name on things like plane tickets credit
cards add a little lord in front of it
you'll look bloody classy they also give
you an official certificate confirming
your lord's ship and this also contains
your unique plot number with the exact
location of your land bow before me punk
i am lord kevin spoilers ruler of this
realm of spoilerdom
now on top of this established titles
have told me that the first 200 people
to use my link below you'll be placed in
a plot within walking distance of mine
and we can be best mates depending on
how many of you want to become a lord or
a lady it just means we can build our
heavy spoilers kingdom together and be
there forever close to each other the
labor day is right around the corner and
established titles have put together a
sale where you can claim 10 off any
purchase i've linked it in the
description below and all you have to do
is go to establishtitles.com
slash heavy spoilers and enter heavy
spoilers at the checkout to get that 10
off at establishtitles.com
spoilers enter heavy spoilers at the
checkout and get yourself 10 off it
makes a great last minute gift it helps
the environment and it's also just a bit
of fun i bid the farewell fellow lord i
shall see thee in the rest of the video
take care
farewell now we cut to an era under the
weirwood tree that we saw in episode 1.
the carvings on these were created by
the children of the forest and
eventually when they were pushed north
the men who invaded the land ended up
worshiping them several episodes in the
original series had them bowing and
taking oaths before these trees and they
were supposed to represent the gods of
the forest here due to all the cushions
we see how ray pretty much uses it as a
place to hang out and read and she of
course did this in the first episode on
the knees of alicent however she wasn't
too interested in the traditions back
then whereas here she's engrossed in a
book showing how much her mindset has
changed the friendship isn't what it
used to be and with her dad taking a new
wife and having a new family she's very
much become pushed out now the books
kind of depicted allison as being
someone who was hungry to have aegon
sitting on the throne but here she does
try to extend an olive branch to
rhaenyra we'll likely see how this
constant rebuffing causes issues down
the line and the pair end up splitting
into separate sides as we get further
into the story code of the family riding
out of the royal hunt which will mark
aegon's second birthday we can't catch
him in the carriage and here we see him
playing with a model of the black dread
dragon valerian this was for saras's
dragon and not only did he have a model
of it last week but we saw a statue of
it in the square during episode 1. this
was really fun of it and he kept its
skull beneath the cube which we also
visited in that same entry now we don't
know what dragon egg was placed in
aegon's crib but i hope he doesn't get
egg on his face when he sees the tension
he's born into
now allison is also pregnant with
another child who we know from the books
ends up being called helena one of the
main issues that arises between the pair
has seed sown in this entry as viz
refuses to remove rhaenyra as the heir
even though alison keeps popping out
these kids she was of course pushed into
getting close to this by her father in
the hopes that the pair would have
children together and one would end up
sitting on the throne biz desperately
wants renera to have a child too but
knowing what happened with her mother
you can see why she's not too thrilled
at the idea the child would also be born
into a time where every error is being
looked at and scrutinized and this will
put it into direct conflict with
alison's offspring now at this point we
hear a nod to egg on the conqueror
this lad's obviously not done much
conquering though but this is a nod to
an ancestor of his aegon the conqueror
was the first targaryen king and he took
over six of the seven kingdoms later on
at the campfire viserys also says how he
had a dream in which his son wore the
conqueror's crown this vision pushed him
to obsess over having his son and it
very much led to emma's death the crown
actually appears in the title sequence
and we open with a sigil of dragons
representing old valyria this city ended
up falling and the crown then remains
behind showing aegon's rise also they
keep saying aegon i've always thought
was aegon but i will be following the
pronunciation in the series and just
saying egg on even if it doesn't sound
as cool because it just reminds you of a
big egg
and whilst he's provided out front and
cheered for ranira sits behind in the
chariot no one really wants her there
and they're all more bothered by the
male heir who everyone thinks should
oust her at this point we meet laris
strong whose nickname lara's club but
due to one of his feet twisting at birth
him sitting with the ladies because he's
not good at hunting actually has a great
second side to it that we learn more
about in the source material now though
it seems like he's just resting up it's
actually laying the groundwork for him
to become the master of whispers which
is a role that he got in the books
lariss in the source material is
described as being someone who tends
just to listen rather than speaking and
we see that very subtly playing out here
lady kira then starts asking lots of
dumb questions about damon even though
rhaenyra hasn't seen him since the
bridge it's clear that the women know
things have devolved into war even if
the crown isn't officially in the
conflict now outside ronira meets jason
lannister he brings up casterly rock and
also the wall which you'll likely know
from the main series he lays it on
factor 50 thick ranira runs off and
maybe mate you'd have better luck with
your sisters viserys gets angry over
this too and he has a blood at the
wedding saying that even he doesn't
exist above tradition he was kind of
forced into his marriage with alison and
in some ways he wasn't really over emma
but the council said that he had to
secure the realm there's still a lot of
talk about how he should have married
him with the valerians which his council
once more tells him to now this
massively ties in with the book and one
of the main reasons that he keeps ronira
as the air here is because he viewed the
whole allison thing as being a way to
secure the realm he was also advised by
others not to marry her so he's just
sticking with the original plan because
he wants to keep the peace now one of
viserys's big character flaws is that he
tried to live up to the legacy left
behind by jiharis because he ruled over
a time of peace and tranquility viz
doesn't want to cause any conflict so he
basically just becomes a people pleaser
rey ends up riding away from the party
and at this point she's pursued by
kristin cole i might have been watching
a bit too much westworld but i found it
interesting that their horses are black
and white showing how they are somewhat
opposite
and they opposites attract
terrible easter egg that now she's
annoyed that her dad just sees her as
being someone who could raise up the
lord of casterly rock but as we know the
lannisters do end up on the throne come
the main series bit of sexual tension
here between kristen and rhaenyra as the
pair go through the woods and he of
course asked for her favor during the
tony in the first episode we also
learned his father was at black haven
which was a castle in the dornish
marches now from here we could at the
hunt which is something that saw the end
of robert baratheon he was skewed by a
wild boar hey you want to see the
biggest boar in robert baratheon's life
meet his good friend ned stark i said
his good friend ned stark a bloody ball
i'm here all week
now a ball ends up popping up in the
entry and we also hear mention of a
certain colored stag
what's the stag like he's white
he's white what do you think
now in westeros white stags were seen as
being good omens however the one viserys
comes face to face with isn't white at
all and he fails to give the killing
blow first strike very symbolic here as
it shows how he's losing his edge and
that the future isn't with him however
who it does appear in front of is
rhaenyra referred to as the white heart
this was the symbol of royalty before
the dragons were used and to me it shows
that she's the true heir now from here
we see as jason presents the king with a
spear forged in the golden gallery this
was located within casterly rock and it
contained all manner of items from bowls
plates to swords and also spears now
there were even golden teeth made there
and this is a personal gift from the
lannisters you also get a good look at
the valerian steel dagger which viscera
still carries with him this of course
appeared throughout game of thrones and
it was the weapon that ended up being
used to kill the night king biz grifted
tightly when delivering the speech at
the end of episode 1 and i love that we
see it constantly popping up with him
now jason asks for an era's hand in
marriage again and he says that he'd
make up for her loss in station everyone
is assuming that aegon is going to be
king and viscera starts to get paranoid
that there might even be a rebellion at
some point this comes to fruition as
well were there eventually being two
factions created called the greens and
blacks now it started getting even
bigger nons vibes than last week when
otto suggests that rhaenyra marries her
two-year-old stepbrother instead of
jason lannister it's pretty messed up
but otto was a very wise man and he
could see that the war was coming
between the two sides he knew that it
would fracture the houses right down the
middle with something in that rhaenyra
should be queen as they already swore
their loyalty to her in episode one
however others would want a male air
above all else so otto was just trying
to stop this from happening but yeah
nonce that was actually commonplace in
the targaryens for them to marry their
brothers sisters uncles aunties nephews
and nieces and hey maybe that jon snow
and dany scene could end up getting
referenced at some point down the line
we get more shots here of this looking
unhinged and it very much echoes the
insanity that would come with the mad
king the targaryens insisted that
keeping it in the family was the best
way to go about it but we know from
signs that this causes numerous genetic
issues every time there's interbreeding
all the faulty genes end up being
carried across and because there's not
someone without them to negate them from
another family these genes end up
getting more dominant this was the case
in real life with the german royal
family who all did the same thing it
eventually led to something called the
habsburg jaw which made their chins look
like jimmy hill after he'd had a hard
night of e so all these factors
eventually play into the mad king being
born which causes the house to be ousted
from the throne now at this point it
suggested that rhaenyra marry in with
the valerians for the reasons that were
suggested last time and also because it
would take away the dates that beers did
by turning his daughter away selena is
mentioned is fighting in the stepstones
and we eventually meet him later on
during the conflict now out in the woods
the little cozy campfire is interrupted
with ranira getting the best offer for
something on top of her that she's had
all day kristen saves her life and the
pair grow even closer than before which
might lead to some trouble down the line
now in front of the fire becerras tells
alison that he named the air out of love
i love the way how allison calls him
okay and it shows that it's very much
ceremony though i know people kind of
view their relationship a bit
differently i have my own opinions on it
but yeah let me know how you interpreted
this line now back at the keep otto
meets with his daughter gonna have to
crop out all this edit and if you go if
you go back and look at this scene
there's a mural on the wall there where
there's four people banging can't show
mate but it's a gangbang and go back and
look because it is pretty funny anyway
alison is aware that aegon is going to
cause issues with ronira and otto talks
about how unpopular viserys will be if
he doesn't announce him as the new heir
the laws of god and men at the time
dictated that men should rule and i love
how reluctant that alison is it's very
much just her father once more pushing
her to go and convince him to make a new
announcement and it's all auto just
manipulating things behind the scenes
now one detail that you might notice
here is that viserys is missing two
fingers as we saw last week his little
one was infected and this clearly spread
to his other throughout the majority of
the entry he wears gloves but we finally
see that two are gone in episode one he
stated that the cut on his back was
caused by the throne and we also saw as
he ended up slicing his little finger
after he sent damon away in the book
george or martin described how you had
to sit on the throne in a certain way in
order to avoid getting cut if you were
cut whilst you wanted it showed you were
not fit to rule symbolizing why viserys
was a bad leader but i think he's all
right now i doubt the throne ever gets
cleaned as well and it is possible that
this could be tetanus or something else
though we initially thought it was
greyscale it's got him for too long now
and a lot of you had other theories
about what it could be this included
diabetes and other diseases that he
might have picked up from just the
hygiene and died at the time either way
i love how the throne is constantly
causing viserys to rot from the inside
showing that he's not really fit to sit
on the throne they never mention any of
this in the book so it is difficult to
fully nail down what it is so let me
know your thoughts below on what you
think is going on now it turns out that
vaymon valerian has reached out for help
but viserys doesn't want to rock the
boat by sending aid as it will show he
supports people who initially went
against him he believes this will cement
that he's weak and he's very much just
in a catch-22 situation where he's
constantly making people angry by trying
to please others we do get a shot of the
letter and i paused it for you so you
can see that talks about asking for
swords and also healthy soldiers now
viserys's reply later gets read out loud
and we to meet bayman who is the brother
of corliss he realizes that killing crab
feeder is better for the realm and thus
he sends in some help however damon
would rather just do it himself and he
even ends up shooting the messenger upon
receiving word from his brother while
not shooting but
smashing him like you should smash that
like button never mind now whereas my
dad used to constantly say never get
married but cerris is still banging on
about it however this time he allows
ronira to find her own match and he also
promises that she won't be supplanted
whether he is very much the one who's
keeping that in check and it's going to
be interesting to see if the
circumstances change now from here we go
to the step stones and i love this slow
pull back from the battle to the forces
gathered on another island set such an
atmosphere seeing the ship slowly roll
in whilst the dragon swarms the sky
there's also a bit of foreshadowing that
sets up what's to come the crab feeder
in his men have no reason to leave those
caves we must give them one who damon
decides to use himself as bay to draw
crab feeders forces out the caves he
doesn't want his brother's help as it's
somewhat of a humiliation to him that he
would need others to come to his aid and
thus he rides out on his own it leads to
a massive action scene and this reminded
me a lot of the battle of the bastards
just in the same way that jon snow
rushed ahead we get the same thing with
daemon too we even have similar shots
where we see the pair from behind
echoing this final charge i was kinda
good at the diamond turned kragus into
krabby patty this early on and after
thinking he might be a big antagonist he
gets cut down pretty quickly his death
differs from how it's in the source
material and in that he was beheaded
whereas here is cleveland too i think
it's way more impactful as i'm kind of
desensitized to the headings at this
point and watching damon drag him along
like a suitcase is an image i think will
stick in everyone's minds for a while
now you do have to kind of suspend your
sense of disbelief here as i feel like
damon is a bit like vamp from metal gear
solid 2 when it comes to arrows hundreds
are fired at him throughout the battle
without most of them hitting him though
they do eventually get a couple of hits
in now there's a nice bit of detail here
on his armor as he kneels down and you
can see where the arrow hit him from
earlier in the episode these arrows
raining down also share some
similarities to the battle of the
bastards and overall it makes for a
really thrilling action scene you see
how merciless and brutal that demon is
and you start to understand why the
council was so worried about him
becoming king he's obsessed with
bloodshed and bearing dragons also makes
him a very fearsome warrior and whereas
crab feeder's luck has changed from the
source material his soldiers aren't the
clothes and armor that these wear
actually look a lot like how crab feeder
is depicted in the book and they all
rush daemon hope seems lost but this was
all part of the plan with it being a way
to draw out crab feeders forces so that
the valyrian army and dragon could
strike at once at this point laying all
rides in on his white dragon which we
know from the source material is called
sea smoke the beast completely
demolishes the arches and after crab
beater flees into his cave damon goes in
after him it's a great way to end the
episode and this was again another
really enjoyable entry we've had three
weeks now where i've been gripped by the
show and at the moment this is my
favorite thing on tv it's so well
written shot and paced that i can't not
admire what they've done with the series
i thought i was out after season eight
but this has pulled me right back in and
those some other [ __ ] have done it
again three really solid episodes and i
also hope that you've been enjoying the
breakdown so far obviously let me know
if you think they're great if you think
they're crap i don't mind reading that
either drop your thoughts on the
breakdown drop your thoughts on the
episode drop your thoughts on the book
let's all have a look anyway we already
covered such a crap creating that i
don't know why i thought that was clever
but yeah we're running competition right
now and giving away three copies of
topka maverick on the 15th of september
and all you have to do to be on the
chance of winning is like the video make
sure you subscribe notifications on and
drop a comment below with your thoughts
on the episode you pick the comments at
random at the end of the month and the
winners of the last one are on screen
right now save that to you then message
me on twitter at heavy spoilers you want
to be able to watch the makeshift or
brighton of lord of the rings which will
be linked on screen right now we go over
all the stuff you need to know about
that too so get get over that why the
hell are you there anyway without the
way thanks for watching through this
hope you enjoy yourself and i'll see you
in the next one take care peace